today regulators from the Food and Drug
Administration will consider a
potentially safer alternative to
cigarettes Philip Morris International
that's a maker of Marlboro and other top
brands once the FDA to approve a new
tobacco device it's called
IKOS the company says the pen-like
product creates an aerosol that's like
less toxic than cigarette smoke and
poses less risk of disease
smoking is a leading cause of
preventable deaths in the u.s. Tony to
cope will recently went to Toronto
Canada where IKOS is already available
to learn about the product and the
science behind it Tony good morning good
morning
we should point out that unlike an
e-cigarette which uses a liquid
containing nicotine IKOS uses sticks of
real tobacco warming them to below the
temperature that produces smoke that
according to Philip Morris can save
lives but critics worry the primary goal
is profit as traditional cigarette sales
dry up not far from Niagara Falls all
right here we go
on our way to Canada on a hip street in
Toronto Philip Morris is building what
it says is the future of tobacco this is
an I coast batik one of many now open in
about 30 countries where Philip Morris
promises to quit traditional cigarettes
and sell IKOS instead like you're not
even in
tobacco shop Philip Morris International
and it's us partner Altria did not
accept our request for an interview or a
demonstration of IKOS so we came here to
Toronto to experience the sales process
ourselves over the sound of a noisy
espresso machine
we heard Aiko's pitched as a cleaner
alternative to traditional cigarettes in
a statement to CBS this morning Philip
Morris International said our goal is to
convert every adult smoker who would
otherwise keep smoking to smoke-free
products such as IKOS we are also clear
that IKOS is not risk-free what Philip
Morris does argue in its FDA application
is that if smokers converted to IKOS it
would significantly reduce harm and the
risk of tobacco-related disease nicotine
is what gets people hooked but USC
professor Adam Leventhal worries IKOS
might actually drive people back to
cigarettes what concerns me I think is
that this looks like a cigarette reminds
you of a cigarette and we know if you
get reminded of of cigarettes and you're
trying to quit it's a high-risk
situation it makes you want to go back
to smoking Leventhal is an expert on
smoking and public health we better turn
this off I'm worried about mine you
genuinely work out alright there we go
the American Cancer Society cautions
most of the research on IKOS has been
funded by Philip Morris a recent
independent study concluded that the
physical effects of IKOS on users are
not yet known on the continuum right you
have air here over here you have some
sort of toxic gas and then you have
cigarettes then probably somewhere in
the middle heat not burned products like
IKOS and then somewhere down here
electronic cigarettes potentially Philip
Morris says it welcomes independent
studies and encourages third parties to
conduct their own research on smoke-free
products and to verify our science some
American smokers like
Indiana resident Amy Lane aren't waiting
for the FDA to rule on IKOS what I knew
back then in 2013 was that tobacco
combusted cigarettes were absolutely
going to kill me after smoking for 22
years she's now a seller of e-cigarettes
and a smoke-free advocate who makes
special trips to London to get IKOS for
personal use so when you ask about well
what happens with Philip Morris you know
they've lied in the past of course they
have but what happens to my body how I
feel compared to when I was smoking
combustible cigarettes there is no
question that I feel 100% better
the FDA's preliminary review of IKOS
found fewer harmful chemicals but
incomplete information regarding tobacco
related disease Philip Morris has two
separate applications before the FDA
today's issue involves whether Aiko's
can be marketed as a reduced harm
product the other application is for
basic sales and Wall Street expects that
to be approved as soon as next month no
it's sort of interesting to look at it
because it looks so much like a
cigarette my mother died of I believe
heavy smoking from a heart attack so
when I see and I'm thinking what can we
do to just reduce it altogether
yeah if the claims being made before the
FDA are accurate this stands to save
millions of lives but that is an if that
researchers are looking at closely thank
you Tony thanks very much